the people of haiti have dealt with
similar devastation but it doesn't
lessen the horror nor the panic
as water flows through the streets
people ask desperately where it's coming
from the threat of a tsunami looming
we'll do it
[Music]
the earthquake struck at breakfast time
buildings folding in on themselves with
little warning the epicenter was 75
miles from the capital porto prince and
many of these areas are cut off from
rescue teams
people dig through rubble with garden
spades and their bare hands
following the screams of family and
neighbours
on this occasion they're successful
rescuing a woman and young boy despite
the danger of more aftershocks
but hundreds of people are confirmed to
have died and most expect that number
will continue to rise
haiti is a
poor country as you know it does but uh
we
we we never prepared for anything happen
even is a um earthquake or whatever it
is
haiti was still recovering from the 2010
earthquake which took more than 200 000
lives scarred impoverished and angry at
government which has failed to rebuild
but nature has no respect for how much
the people of this country have suffered
along the same fault line a shake even
more powerful than the one which caused
such loss and this is a country already
on its knees reeling from the
assassination of its president last
month overtaken in some areas by violent
gangs
are you concerned about a potential
humanitarian crisis given how precarious
the situation was in haiti even before
this earthquake yeah it's unfolding
right before our eyes very concerned um
it was it's been a very difficult two
two and a half years for
the people of haiti because of political
unrest because of covid
and now this the full extent of the
destruction and death is still unknown
because many of the communities affected
are rural and hard to reach haiti is
also in the path of tropical storm grace
which could hamper rescue efforts for
the people of this island the onslaught
of bad fortune continues
martha kellner sky news